[Music]
in Mythbusters news it's a little
bubbles with those in the bathtub
the one host isn't most interesting man
I've ever met his life story is really
cool the one that looks like a walrus
yeah on Mythbusters
oh yeah all right submitted by guac is
extra I hate how guac is always extra
this list of bunks 100 of the most
common myths take it away to see you
yeah it's so obviously we're not gonna
talk about all hundred but just I would
be kind of cool to you know about these
common myths so there's one that says
food before swimming you know how
there's a myth there you're not supposed
to eat before he's when I heard that
don't matter I still follow that eating
does not increase the risk of
experiencing muscle cramps there's no
port there is a correlation however with
alcohol and drowning oh wait I didn't
know about cuz a muscle cramp you just
don't want to kid the Yak in the pool
yeah cuz I bought me yeah I bought was a
cramping remember I can't swim you know
I thought it's cuz kids were throwing up
in pools II ate like a [ __ ] and
I went swimming in our queue yeah where
they [ __ ] in the pool yeah you should
think like the water changed the the
physics of your body or something cuz
you're floating in water so that food or
just come up or something just the other
day me in Christina went to go swim in
our pool and I was just like man I'm too
[ __ ] full so I waited
I thought follow me you know I'm just
too full to swim around you shouldn't
just go in and like yeah I can't because
my dog is too crazy running around the
pool and [ __ ] I'll play fetch with him
in the pool yeah you guys got a pool
come over it's been hot as [ __ ] dude I
just [ __ ] going to pull any at the
same time I'll be in the ocean with a
[ __ ] like hot dog in my mountain I'm
in the middle of the ocean I can't see
land anymore is so good and
a common myth is that gum dye dress over
years that's not true how long does it
take the truth is like chewing gum is
mostly and adjustable and passes through
the digestive system at the same rate as
other matter
Wow because I've seen that [ __ ] like in
my log it's just a piece of gum oh
really
maintaining your shape knowledge I feel
like these myths started up because like
doctors just didn't it's like it's not
good for you so I'm just gonna make this
[ __ ] up because these kids kept on
swallowing it yeah yeah or parents yeah
so dumb ones like the corn of the candy
world exactly bad for you though is it
like swallowing gum I how bad is it if
it gets stuck somewhere whatever gets
stuck on an organ or something I think
like your organs are too moist to get
stuck you know it's for gum to get stuck
on there it's nice and I just know the
new gum it just disintegrates in your
mouth it's true I [ __ ] hate in a
really it's supposed to get harder and
harder though in its instant to it's
like ours are chewing yo slightly 30
minutes let's meet some old addicted to
gum I would always have gum in my mouth
and that happened to me one time when I
was in a grocery store and there's all
of a sudden those are first time it ever
happened because and I had it sounds
like the morning that piece of gum who
was the Icebreaker no I was and then all
of a sudden I just melt in my mouth
knowing you're panicking I just melt
maybe it's for people who fall asleep
with gum in their mouth and just melt so
they don't die cold gum does that yeah
next one a vitamin C does not prevent
the common cold although it may have a
protective effect during intense cold
weather exercise and may reduce it the
duration of colds all doesn't prevent it
I take my vitamin C in you gummies all
my vitamins are taken and gummies
[ __ ] child dude this guy's addicted
to emergency I'm not just north that I
just have a lot of adrenaline and I know
that the more adrenaline you use and I
guess waste away it takes a toll on your
vitamin
see so I need to drink that [ __ ]
or else I guess sick maybe that's why
you have so much adrenaline because you
drink so much
maybe the next one
waking sleepwalkers have you ever heard
of that coming buh-bye yeah
so it says sleepwalkers can get confused
when woken but not harmed in fact if you
let them sleepwalk they can lose their
balance and fall they're not zombies
wait I'm gonna face have you guys ever
experienced a sleepwalker
yes my brother oh I used to do it oh I
should go so I was in elementary school
at that time and my mom and dad said I
would wake up in the middle of night and
sleepwalk well go around and turn on all
the lights in the house
and then go back to bed yeah and is
weird I have no idea you know do you
know what I did were you conscious I
don't remember any of that
I really only thing I remember is waking
up in front of stairs sometimes or being
in the stairs and just sitting there oh
and they said I used to unlock the front
door and try to go outside well the
moment they told me that and I went to a
friend's house to sleepover they locked
all the doors didn't tell me where their
locks were and like
and when did that thought I don't know
maybe when I started doing drugs in high
school drugs help [ __ ] my girlfriend
who is sleepwalked we shared a hotel
room we had like two separate beds and
this is an Australia I was sleeping and
then looked up or like I I was kind of
trying to fall asleep and then she was
sitting at the edge of the bed facing me
going that's crazy I was like I will
[ __ ] punch you go back to bed I put
her back to bed she took she got up his
ran to the bathroom like so sleepwalking
closed it stayed there for like it's
means like maybe she's pooping dude you
hear about those sleep eaters what yeah
I wake up and they make a full-on
sandwich they eat it you come back to
see I think that's why I can lose weight
I'm asleep either good yeah you're fully
awake you wake up you make yourself a
salmon go full-on
sandwich same [ __ ] same [ __ ] sandwich
and the II think it was like that
special on CNN or 20/20 I forgot but
there's like sleep eaters they eat
within their sleep all the time that's
not like my brother he's do that [ __ ] in
his crib my mom would wake up because
he's in the middle of the night in his
bedroom on the crib saying rice rice in
Chinese it's a fun fun and they have to
wake up make a [ __ ] bowl of rice
cooking for like an hour you know and
[ __ ] yeah and you only want to fresh
rice one there the myth that hair grows
after death so that the skin contracts
and it's dry and it makes the hair stick
out more yeah things see me with nails
exactly like after you dye your hair
still grows on your nails so grow but
that's exactly what happens is that your
skin just get I dry it just dries up and
shrinks away and just makes it look like
there was growth that's true that's kind
of like my belly got flatter and my dick
got bigger it's just not really it's the
same last wait another myth
MSG headaches so the Chinese sent
Chinese restaurant syndrome is a large
is largely admit I knew it there is
no Pharisee there is no large study that
shows that msg triggers mine green have
you guys ever tried MSG straight up yeah
yeah I just said crystal cracked it's
[ __ ] weird like my eye it wasn't a
jar and my grandma's like oh you want
you ain't good and it's like stick my
finger in it was it grossest thing ever
it makes me taste so good huh it pinches
your totally spicy like like those like
pop rocks
sometimes I go to venom use restaurants
and then they have msg like in a salt
shaker mm-hmm yeah and it's just sitting
behind a chicken and [ __ ] yes are the
chicken the poor do when I go to a full
restaurant and says hey all-natural no
MSG I know [ __ ] this place skimp on me
[ __ ]
another common myth is a Twinkies never
expire they do cool yeah they have a
show shelf-life of 45 days oh really
hmm the zombie movie lied to me dude why
are Twinkies so good never liked it I
always like the the cupcakes better
cause Ho Hos the hostess cupcakes but
the little just so goddamn funny how
they denied everything from the little
Debbie's like the whole box is just a
dollar and [ __ ] good with milk I get
with our Impala God oh I I can take like
two three bites I'm like see those
things no like you have to have it with
the [ __ ] time you say every year you've
gotten you down I drink it with I mean I
drink coffee with it have you had the
Texas moon pies though oh my god yes
wait a little Debbie ones it's like a
circle and it's the inside in a circle
it's a like a sandwich oh my god good
another myth the 50/50 coin flip so
they're saying that a coin has a
slightly higher chance of landing on the
side that was facing up before the flip
wife at Stanford University recorded
thousands of flips the results was 49 50
Oh
much stuff I love what this was a
research at Stanford 49:51 what do I 51
women were since I love that Stanford
math is a little bit off you can't say
no man so there's a whole list of common
myths if you guys are curious go check
out the link in the description I gotta
check that [ __ ] yeah there's a ton hey
guys thanks for watching that last video
make sure to follow us on instagram @ JK
films to watch more videos right up
there
[Music]